we're on the polish ukrainian board at
the moment we've been inside one of the
temporary refugee centers that they have
here and it is i have to say
a pretty miserable place there is a very
large room which would have been the
tesco supermarket floor which just
crammed with about 600 beds uh it is
pretty miserable in there lots of people
in there waiting for transport are just
simply trying to get some sleep because
they've just been traveling uh for days
and days and days uh one of those that
is outside here that we've got a chance
to have a chat with is taisha
and her little baby selena salami
thank you
um
you've come
from kiev but you've got family in
kharkiv yes how has your journey been
it was difficult because
when we went to
came to chiakasi from kiev it was um uh
syrian i don't know we will how to say
maybe no it was
siren yes it was siren and all of time
we need to go to a very
very bad place
underground yes underground yes it is
not sanitary
there are no century
uh
it is very
scary place
and we
need to be
when siren was in
sky and
you know after that after maybe a
seven hour we
came to cherkasi and with my mother we
live for a few days
we want
[Music]
silence we want
a good place but
there is no silence
now there are siren too and
avia
some some
avia attacks maybe and after that
next
how
you must be utterly exhausted traveling
with a little baby on your own
you must be so tired yes
she was very scary and all of our trip
she cried
when we was in this underground
here crying and
i
i
i teach some psychological method
methods to help her because
it was very difficult and uh
yesterday we
from cherkasi we came to poland because
my
nervous
is not good and all of night i uh uh i
uh
scream i uh crime and i
uh
and uh
yes yes but but you've you've left your
family behind you've left your husband
behind it's not surprising that things
are really hard
our my husband and our father
crying when he
sent us to bus and now
we are
we pray
for god
for
peace in our country and for peace in
our family we want to be
a vision with enough with all of our
family in kiev
we live our peace life and
to
give our daughter a happy future
very best of luck to you i hope that
happens i really do tasha thank you very
much for talking to us and sky thank you